tokyoflash enflammé talonner la course
est qu'un disque dur on a sorti les
grandes pales grandes pales la grande
vague et parce qu'il ya un peu de gaudi
pouvait dit laguiole à rester au vent
j'ai l'impression que j'ai à mes applis
t-il appaloosa est un peu plus trop
aller que le fr champions meilleur champ
clos rationnelle et à bayonne et au vent
va ya beaucoup d'animations abord il
faut garder les efforts qui sont faits
sur la paille est vous stabilisez lier
vous la faire rester dans le vent à
virer la bouée mais toujours avec deux
objectifs le premier c'est d'assurer la
vitesse du bateau et le deuxième c'est
de contrôler laguiole qui vient des
organes les efforts qu'ils sont en train
d'être fournis par les autres ça il faut
de l'entraînement pour faire ça il faut
tous les voies dressé ne sont pas
remplies les hommes à l'intérieur ça
veut dire qu'il ya pas beaucoup de vent
le vent un peu un petit peu descendu je
pense qu'on est dans 10-12 noeuds elle
vivait sa bouille alors on ne voit pas
la yole j'ai appelé jab les appétits la
palmosa qui est derrière mais elle doit
être très proches mais bien contrôler et
s'assurer qu'elles restaient derrière en
lui donnant ce qu'on appelle le mauvais
vent regarder ailleurs il ne va pas
aussi vite que les rues de devant parce
que le vent même si elle est plus toilé
voile et ils vont certainement se
débarrasser de tête de l'équipe
gilles aillaud pour faire un final en
beauté mais là le finish de cette de ce
prologue est tout à fait roman l'arrivée
des mineurs
concernant les deux premiers cols lui
est fait en fleurs du robert et zapetti
gerblé l'appaloosa de la ville du
françois match
robert lefranc pas et puis derrière en
cherche notamment cddm edf qui était en
troisième position
attention c'est l'arrivée c'est
l'arrivée oui je passais la boisson vers
l'arrivée la bouille avait été déplacée
cette voie là avec le vent qui est passé
au dessus et je pense qu'à laurent
gbagbo et de la faune s'il arrivait que
nous allons tous les supporters bien sûr
dumas père sont la vraie n'est venu on
va me revoir un peu l'arrivée en direct
de réception lui fr les gens sont
carrément pratiquement dans l'eau
il vient d'accueillir loriol tout de
suite il ya zapetti juste à faire
au losc on s'attend bien sûr à gaza
prédit alors votre glisser quelques
secondes pour l'interview la réaction
notamment de félix mérine qui remporte
ce prologue disputé dans la baie de
fort-de-france fait faire un chauffeur
du bus berre qui avait gagné à quelques
semaines la coupe de martinique après sa
suspension de cinq courts et bien il va
faire chaud flop apporte ce polo devant
les appétits gerblé l'appaloosa du
françois est en troisième position c'est
tdm edf de la ville du lamentin quartier
californie mention concernant le trio de
tête le final et la victoire du fn va
appuyer cette idée mérite d'être
discutée que vous avez dit non ce sont
les maths épices et de la pauvreté dans
tel moment qu'on peut à l'appel
rosette/orange peut-être digicel petit
navire et puis christophe d'aidé mais
bon le trio de tête est constitué de
viol qui m
fortes prétentions de grosses
prétentions au bout la victoire finale
et c'était des iem qui avait fait appel
à elle va ou non oui comme équipiers
vont il est inscrit depuis depuis le
milieu de la saison il s'inscrit d'abord
en tant qu'équipier dons soit une
invitée de prestige c'est bon pour nous
d'être vue d'avoir moment
comme été défini en france elles seront
relayées par françois laizeau
participer à la course ça va attirer
encore plus le regard des navigateurs
les négatifs à 16,7
cette prestigieuse
peut-être lors des prochaines éditions
nouveau monde
ben voyons c'est ici à bordeaux appelle
tabarly avait discuté et a fait du tour
en 1987 je vous en tant que skipper
graba rôle devant l'éternel il faisait
partie de l'équipage km/h est avalé été
missionné qui passe de richards le nom
et quelques chances françaises je n'ai
jamais gagné de parler non c'est parce
qu'ils étaient partis à l'extérieur à
l'option grand père vit et que nous avec
une petite chose qu'à bien alors la
victoire du fn champion de la baie du
robert réaction avec khalid abu à venir
allaient aux ali pour peut-être les
autres ya les autres lieux où sont elles
à les écouter camille effectivement donc
que vous avez un véhicule à l'arrivée
donc à des trois premières à embarquer
sur la quatrième vous le savez c'est
donc la yole te fort de france on peut
trembler un petit minutes ensuite
arrivent les robertet de cotrel gf1
caraïbes et puis nous avons également
donc mutuellement gaïa qui a connu
quelques petites difficultés on va dire
au niveau du passage de la première
bouée au niveau donc de pointe l'edhec
le mutuelle makaya qui va arriver en de
4,5 en sixième position
ensuite arrivera donc en brasserie
lorraine laguiole bas-rhinoise mais
attention parce que c'est pas qu'on fait
pour un but seulement gaïa ils n'ont pas
encore assuré et non pas encore assurée
l'on réussit sa place parce que derrière
ya un bras si le raid qui semble revenir
vers
on verra ça sera un procure notre
mutuelle mare gaillard et brasserie
lorraine
ça va être bon c'est vrai bon pour un
beagle marc gaillard avec notamment marc
lagier brasserie lorraine qui va donc
franchir dans quelques instants
également cette ligne d'arrivée puis
derrière et vous le savez a quand même
plusieurs autres centres imprécis
attendait notamment rosette/orange il ya
d'ailleurs cette année est donc
exceptionnelle de cet avis la semaine
petits coquillages également arrivent
petit à leur visite à laguiole choqué
d'oise
et puis on a également une autre viol
c'est à lutter stocks à lui des stades
pour sa beauté qui va également donc
arriver dans quelques instants ici donc
sur cette plage de la française ou
effectivement positionner sur l'autre
regardons le public présent ses choix je
peux dire que c'est chaud et à faire
espérer lui il a déjà envoyé même si ce
n'est que le prologue
mais la cob a envoyé un signal fort donc
assez un principaux concurrents alors on
va peut-être rappeler les poussières
volcaniques ufr chanflor les
appétits la valouse assez tdm tremplin
ville de fort de france et sont donc
arrivés suivis de jf à cotrel
mutuellement gaïa ensuite arrive donc je
voulais 10,1 brasserie la lorraine
et puis express de cette année également
qu'il va pas tarder à arriver celui
d'établissement aux aides à lui des
stocks également et puis les autres
embarcations comme c'est un petit peu
d'énergie
monsieur bricolage royal ce weed man tu
dis que c'est la dernière embarcations
qui est encore très très loin alors si
on regarde le classement de ce prologue
puis f1 champions donc a fait d'une
pierre deux coups la victoire et le
maillot rouge de leader mais il faut
revenir quand même se brasse qui noël 7e
septième de cette cause et plus vous
êtes le yen
oui mais comme je vous dis ce n'est pas
bon ce n'est pas significatif parce que
s'ils l'ont fait ce qu'elles ont plus
ils ont regardé sur tous les abonnés
c'est à pouvoir le positionnement et de
mère mon avis ce sera une autre chanson
lorsque les conditions météo était
incertaine
le choix des voiles a certainement été
déterminant
lorsqu'on a franchement on assure je ne
suis pas je suis pas inquiet de voir le
l'opposition et la contrebande
d'ailleurs à face à bien par rapport à
mes premiers qui font des stocks à mieux
peut-être qu'elle a un mauvais réglage
choisi peut-être que nous à nous à 10 le
sommet parce que ce n'est pas tellement
élevé sa réponse et nous a pas vraiment
répondu sur le la taille de sa voix la
dimension de savoir non seulement ce
n'est que le premier sonic le premier
tour un produit premiers sont passés au
comédien crayon mais pas sa phrase est
allée rosalie je pense que phoenix où il
a encore frappé aujourd'hui pour le
coupé l'épisode voilà docte la victoire
du fn showfloor au terme de ce pôle
revient également sur l'analyse de ce
prologue
jean l'experte rappelé que la fosse du
prologue 4e
oui mais ce comportement lors de la
conférence de presse à la mairie avait
avancé des choses qui m'a un peu surpris
mais quand ils avaient annoncé qu'ils
seraient en bonne place
ils ne sont aujourd'hui c'est très bien
d'arriver dans la
capital de faire parler de soi je pense
que supporters de cette fouille à l'aise
baie des flamands sont extrêmement
content mais il va falloir confirmer à 7
jours vous confirmez il ya fort de
france qui n'est pas une ville une ville
de niort de tout bon parce qu'il faut
peut-être 20 sera c'est un super patron
il ya une équipe de jeunes qu'il faut
former une association toujours mais ils
ont commencé à faire de la vega je crois
que les efforts sont payants il en bonus
s'il arrive à déterminer quels vous
combien s'en faut y aller à les suivre
nous avons un peu d'argent pour acheter
de bonne voie ils seront dans le coup
mais c'est une très belle performance au
public en la personne de josé amaro
français a fait un travail considérable
jusqu'à 1 et donc ils ont de l'espoir il
espère peut-être la saison prochaine
gagner une étape pourquoi pas avoir un
bon placement dans le top 10 pourquoi
pas oui tremplin des ministres en pleine
ville de fort-de-france leafs qu en
plusieurs plusieurs pensionnaires ils
ont changé ne pas entonner alors ouest
avec nos pour 7,4 à voir kelly babeau
avec peut-être et l'ex-speakerine ont un
dossier de laguiole ufr il s'agit de
fait exprès mais c'est très difficile à
dire
ils sont françois alabrune nous on est
tout seul c'est cela qui sont très beaux
objets volés chaque jour
château mais c'est comme ça ne sert à
rien pour moi c'est mes jeux